c'est ce que j'appelle une grosse
présidentielle monsieur tous les jours
la même blague forêt de quoi serait fait
des gens comme vous le bourbon et
d'erreurs de jugement avec un niveau de
surveillance sans précédent
ce n'est pas seulement un sommet des
plus puissants dirigeants du monde
c'est l'événement le plus sécurisé sur
terre bienvenue à londres monsieur le
président qu'est ce qui se passe rien
c'est ce qui me fout les boules on joue
une attaque c'est la capitale
britannique
des dirigeants mondiaux ont été tués
reste maintenant on va vous évacuer le
président des états unis
non
est porté disparu
à nos vieux amis de l'ouest barkaoui
numéro 6 sur 10 vous voulez quoi votre
président
ça ne risque pas d'arriver ce sont tous
ceux qui pourront désormais mourir
que vous venez de condamner il faut
trouver par cas oui avant qu'ils
trouvent le président
nous allons le tuer lentement et le
diffuser en direct avait il faudra être
un peu plus nombreux
veux pas qu'on me exécute pour de la
propagande
ne les laissez pas m'enlever si jamais
ça devait arriver tu aimeras c'est un
ordre londres n'est que la première
étape
imaginez toutes les capitales du monde
sombrant dans le cas
votre président meurt ce soir
devant ceux qui menacent notre liberté
l'amérique se les voir aller
vous y trompez pas nous vous trouverons
et nous ferons anéantiront
on va vous expliquent très partant non
sur le toit agresseurs n'auraient pour
un tacle
oh mon dieu